well thanks very much sarah for the kind
introduction and also for the invitation
to present this webinar
i'm really delighted to be here and to
share some of our latest work with the
listeners
so the work that i'm going to tell you
about today has to do with our interest
in developing next-gen therapeutics
targeting hiv integration
this particular biological process the
integration of the viral genome into
target host cells
has been of interest in the lab for some
time now and
describe some of the structural biology
of the nuclear protein assemblies that
perform
this process but this process is also
targeted by some of the latest
and really the best available
antiretroviral therapeutics
and there's active chemical development
in the in the area
so with some of the continuous
developments in cryo-em more recently
what we realized is that we can now
utilize advanced imaging and crossing
strategies to understand how small
molecules
bind to these nuclear protein assemblies
that catalyze integration
and really to utilize the workflows for
a structure-based
drug design so i'm extremely excited to
share this story with you today
so my lab is a structural biology lab we
use cryo-electron microscopy or cryo-em
to understand macromolecular structure
why study structure
well structure describes function so we
are
interested in not only understanding how
macromolecular complexes are assembled
and why certain types of assemblies
might occur we're interested
in the atomic level details at the level
of individual residues and base pairs
which of these may play functional roles
we want to know how to perturb
macromolecular function
by modifying the structure and
ultimately would like to in
to harness the information to improve
human health so thinking
more specifically about rational drug
and vaccine design and finally
we're also interested in methodology
development to facilitate
not only to facilitate structural
studies but also to open up
novel areas of investigation so the main
structural biology technique that we
employ
is single particle cryo now the way it
works is briefly shown in this slide
first one needs to purify a sample of
your macromolecular
object or macromolecular macromolecular
assembly of interest
you then apply that sample onto a three
millimeter
cryovm grid the grid is plunged frozen
into liquid ethane
and the sample is vitrified or frozen in
its native hydrated state this frozen
sample is then
inserted into an electron microscope and
you start to acquire images
now these are the types of images that
one can obtain
and what you see are individual
monodisperse
single images of or single particles
of in this particular case the groel
macromolecular
assembly so we refer to these as
individual particles we can select them
out
and then subject them to a number of
image processing operations that will
ultimately allow you to arrive at a
three-dimensional reconstruction
and if the reconstruction is resolved to
a sufficient to a sufficiently high
resolution
then one can interpret it with an atomic
model
so aquarium is by no means a new
technique it's been around since the
1980s
and really some of the early pioneering
work
was conducted by bob glazer and ken
taylor in the 1970s
there are a number of important
developments in the field and these are
highlighted here
first of all the vitrification
technology now vitrification was
pioneered by jacques dubuche throughout
the 80s
it allows the experimentalists to freeze
molecular specimens
in near native in their near native or
frozen hydrated states
so the sample doesn't get a chance to
crystallize
and vitrification of molecular specimens
really forms the basis of cryovm
a number of early image processing
procedures were developed also in the
80s
for for example assigning orientations
to individual particles for
performing reconstructions and for many
other
steps of the crying workflow
computational methods really constitute
continue to constitute the backbone of
current development
and they're also important
demonstrations of what crayon can do
in 1991 the first atomic structure of
bacterial adoption was determined using
a type of criterium called
called electron crystallography
cryoelectron crystallography
and this showed that we could really
gather important structural information
about macromolecular
assemblies so for these and other
developments these three individuals
jacques de beauche jacob frank and
richard henderson
were awarded the 2017 nobel prize in
chemistry for their work in developing
criem
for the high resolution structure
determination of biomolecules in
solution
now since those early developments there
have been a number of important advances
in more recent years first of all direct
detectors came on the scene
about a decade ago now these detectors
first uh allowed us to acquire images
with
increasing noise ratio both in
comparison to conventional ccd detectors
but also in comparison to
photographic film and second
they allowed us to record movies instead
of still images
now the reason these movies are
important is because the specimen is
actually not
completely still under imaging
conditions so two distinct phenomena
beam induced movement and stage drift
lead to blurry images
however if one records movies then you
can align the individual frames and you
can account for this movement which
then leads to crisper images
algorithm development has played a huge
role software such as reliant cryospark
system they've they really
revolutionized how much we can
extract out of noisy craving images
and finally automation also played an
important role software such as legend
on and serial em
have allowed us to acquire really huge
data sets and
this is necessary not only for pushing
resolution but for making sense of
increasingly more challenging and
heterogeneous
samples now all these developments led
to what we now refer to
as the resolution revolution basically
cumulative advances in the field have
allowed us to solve
very important macromolecular complexes
the ones that are displayed on this
slide here
are the mitochondrial ribosome from
venki's group the trip channel from
euphones group and the
f420 um reducing nickel nickel iron
hydrogenated enzyme from vernacule
bronze group
and this revolution is really allowing
traditional microscopists to
become true structural biologists
so we've seen steady improvements in
resolution since that time
that was around 2013 2014
in the last several years a number of
step two angstrom resolution structures
have come out
so in the first panel a is the beta
galactosidase enzyme from sriram
subramaniam's group and b that's the
adeno-associated virus from our group
and c and d there are several equal
ferritin structures from the groups of
radar dynav
and short shares and the ones on this
slide are actually from early 2019
since then we've seen a number of other
structures come out in the 1.5 to 2
angstrom range
and i would say we can fully expect
these advances to continue
for years to come so we're still not at
the limit at the optical limit of the
microscope
of course people started to take notice
this is a slide showing the cumulative
number of
map depositions into the electron
microscopy databank
you can see that around 2013 there seems
to be an inflection point
and we're now at a time where the
technique is
increasingly growing in popularity
so this increasing popularity also
translates into atomic model depositions
this is a recent tweet from masahire
kikawa
showing the cumulative number of model
depositions into the protein databank
and specifically in comparison to other
methods namely
x-ray crystallography and nmr
spectroscopy
so we are now in 2020
okay we're still about a factor of five
behind
x-ray crystallography in terms of the
number of released
structures per year in the pdb but if
you extrapolate this line
over the last 10 years and extrapolate
it forward
we we really seem to be on an
exponential growth curve
and so this means that by around 2023
2024 we'll be approximately neck and
neck with the crystallographic community
in terms of the model depositions
so that brief introduction i'm going to
get into the meat of my talk
building on these developments that i've
just introduced in crying
what we really wanted to do is to ask
whether we can now
utilize these increasingly powerful
techniques
for the purposes of drug design
targeting hiv integration
my lab is interested in hiv structural
biology
we continue to we've worked in this
field
for almost a decade now we continue to
work on in this field
in part because of this slide if you
look at the
prevalence of global hiv infection
in first world countries the infectivity
rates are relatively low
ranging typically less than one percent
however if you look at other countries
such as
russia such as thailand and virtually
every single country
in sub-saharan africa these rates are
significantly higher
so as of 2017 this is data
from the cdc there are about 37 million
people who are
infected with hiv there's
about two million new cases per year and
about a million deaths
which means that we are now at 20 in
2020 so about 40 million people
who are infected or living with the
virus
only about half at this point a little
bit more than half
are on antiretroviral therapy okay so we
need to do something
to to tackle this really global problem
so let's start with a little bit about
the viral life cycle
so these are the early events that are
displayed on this slide
the virus is at the top it's an envelope
retrovirus which means that it contains
a lipid bilayer that is of host cell
origin
on the surface of this bilayer there are
proteins called envelope glycoproteins
now these proteins bind cd4 receptor and
either the
ccf ccr5 or cxcr4
co-receptors which then triggers a
conformational rearrangement
and leads to diffusion of viral and
cellular membrane
fusion then releases the conical capsid
core which contains two copies of
genomic rna this core is trafficked
along microtubules to the nuclear pore
complex
and during that time the genomic rna is
converted into complementary viral cdna
through reverse transcription
reverse transcription that's really one
of the hallmarks of all retroviruses
after completion of reverse
transcription
and synthesis of viral cdna a multimer
of integrase
proteins can then bind to the ends of
viral dna
to form what's known as a reintegration
complex or a pick
at some point during that whole process
from the conversion
uh from so the conversion from the
reverse transcription complex to a
pre-integration complex
there's also an encoding step and a
translocation step to the nuclear pore
complex
that the timing of all these events is
still poorly understood
but once in the nucleus the pig can scan
target chromatin and identify a select
region for integration
integration then establishes a permanent
and irreversible infection in that
target cell so we are specifically
interested
in the steps involving the pick the pick
is a large and still enigmatic assembly
there's
10 000 base pairs of viral dna there
there's integrase multiples of integrase
there are cellular
host factors probably some capsid viral
capsid
and probably unknown other factors that
are involved it's a big messy complex
and it hasn't been really amenable to
homogeneous isolation for structural
studies
but what we can do is we can assemble
complexes
that contain the basic functional
components of a pick in vitro
these complexes are called intersomes
and endosomes provide
an in vitro system for studying the
cellular pick
what we do is we have oligonucleotides
of viral dna
these are typically 25 to 27 base pairs
in length and we incubate them with
integrase proteins and under specific
biochemical conditions
those can then form into a complex into
nuclear protein assembly that we
call the stable synaptic complex
integrase will then cleave off
two of the nucleotides from the three
prime n to form this the cleave synaptic
complex
uh that complex can then capture
additional target dna
so additional oligonucleotides to form
the target capture complex
and finally integrase will perform its
second catalytic step
to make two nicks in target dna
and insert viral dna into
the target dna so that forms a strand
transfer complex
into some or stc into some
a number of years ago we described the
structure
of the hiv strain transfer complex into
some it's shown here
the lentiviral lymphosome is a large
nuclear protein assembly composed of
viral integrase and
and nucleic acid in the stc entisome
we see two dnas first there's the viral
dna
that's in red there are two copies of
viral dna these represent
the two ends of the viral genome so in
reality these ends are slightly distinct
there's a u3 and a u5 end but in our
case we're simply using two identical
oligos for the u5ns
there's also the host dna and that's
shown in orange
and this particular complex represents
the product of strand transfer
and therefore both the viral dna and the
target host dna are actually joined
together as a single molecule
and the dna in turn is bound
by multimers of viral integrase proteins
so in this assembly there are 12
integrase proteins that form an
oligomeric assembly around the nucleic
acid
there's actually a range in terms of the
number of integrase enzymes that can
assemble around the dna
ends but a few of these really have to
be conserved in order to form a
functional lymphosome
so there are a number of
strand transfer inhibitors that have
been
developed over the last years over the
last
actually several decades
and four of these have been clinically
approved by the fda
raw tag reviewer and lv tegravir these
are first generation inhibitors
whereas w tegravir and big tegravir
these are second generation inhibitors
big tegrity is the latest to have been
approved by the fda it's been improved
in 2018. what's important is that
all of these compounds they bind into
sums they do not
buy free integrase so into sums are the
primary targets for these
leading clinical therapeutics
and as of today there are
approximately 40 or so drug resistant
mutants and they and counting they keep
increasing
so we really want to understand not only
how these compounds bind to the hiv
intestine but also how the virus
acquires resistance getting back to the
assembly mechanism that i introduced a
couple of slides ago
what we know about these inhibitors is
that they work at this particular step
so they inhibit the formation of the
target capture
complex and this also means that they
bind
to the cleave synaptic complex so we can
assemble
the cleave synaptic complex bound to
these inhibitors and we can
utilize and then we can study these
assemblies using structural biology
so we can purify the assemblies just to
briefly mention the purification scheme
we actually
use two gel filtration steps the first
step uses a conventional super
six column even though we get a single
peak on the s6 actually the mixture is
still quite heterogeneous and
we found this out after we started to
use these aggregate columns
tsk gel aggregate columns so if you take
a purified peak from an s6 column
and injected onto the tsk gel column you
can see that there's still
quite a heterogeneous mixture and that's
that's represented by
uh by the blue and red profiles i'm not
going to get into what these
csc stacks are um i'll just
say that we can take the peak that
represents the csc into sums and then
use it for structural biology
and we know that it's at least
reasonably clean because if we re-inject
if we re-inject it onto the same column
there's largely
one peak that remains although the
purification is by no means perfect
and then if we take the intersections
and subject them to an integration assay
we see that
they are competent for cleavage and
that's shown in lane two
of this gel where you see a smear that
represents multiple cleavage events
but if we use inhibitors in lanes two
through six
integration is effectively blocked
so this is what the cryo-em data looks
like here you
see a raw micrograph and 2d class
averages from the data
you can see that there's a little bit of
aggregation that's going on here
this has to do with the fact that the
particles adhere to the air water
interface it's by no means
a an ideal distribution
this really is a sort of a typical
micrograph but nonetheless we can
recover
some nice signal from these uh particles
and get a
reasonably little class averages
now our very first attempt to resolve
the structure of an instinct bound into
some
uh resulted in a map that looks like
this this is a view of the active site
this is where
instead bind and you can see that
there's a significant amount of smearing
that is occurring this has to do with
the preferred orientation problem okay
we have
one and only one preferred uh
orientation
uh of these of these particles in in the
data
we know from alex noble's work that
preferred orientation is really one of
the most common problems
uh current problems in the criteria
field at least using current uh
vitrification
strategies and what we suggested a
number of years ago
is that you can tilt the grid in the
microscope to help
to alleviate resolution anastasia in
this smearing that's caused by preferred
specimen
orientation so the idea is that if you
have a cryovm grid
and so here's a cross section of the
grid particles
tend to absorb either to the top or the
bottom so one of two air water
interfaces
and when you collect data for samples
that exhibit this sort of
behavior you really only get one view of
your
macromolecular object of interest
however
you can tilt the grid during data
collection
inside the microscope and when you do
that you can get a much
better set of orientation orientation
distributions and more
comprehensive set of view sets of views
so when we did this with hiv endosomes
we found that in the absence of tilts on
here on the left you get a very
anisotropic reconstruction
however if you just tilt the data in our
case we used
20 30 and 40 degrees we can get a much
better and much more isotropic
reconstruction
so just briefly as an aside there are
actually a number of benefits to tilting
for these preferentially oriented
samples
you can improve the homogeneity of the
orientation distribution so these are
your euler angles
you improve the directional resolution
by virtue of
a more homogeneous euler angle
orientation distribution or
angular coverage so you get less
antisocial people
and then in a in a more recent
manuscript we actually showed that you
can improve the global resolution by
virtue of improving
uh a factor that we've uh that we
recently introduced called the sampling
compensation factor
so these are the maps that we obtain
using the workflow
on this slide the same map is shown in
three different ways
on the left is the raw map in the middle
is the same map colored by the integrase
proton we're surrounding
and bound to lentivarial dna there's
eight of them or at least domains of
eight integrase protomers and
and on the right is what is known as the
conserved
into some core now the conserved into
some chorus copri
is comprised of integrase protomers
that are as the name implies conserved
among retroviral species so
not all lymphosomes are so large not all
of them form hexadecamers or dodecamers
some are octameric still others are
tetrameric but there's always the
conservation
of the central domains that are colored
in yellow and these
conserved domains are the ones that
perform the catalytic process
so getting back to the map on the left
you can see that there's a lot of
heterogeneity in the peripheral regions
this again has to do with the incomplete
assembly okay but what's important is
that the regions
that are outlined here in red that's the
catalytic site
okay so that's where insteads bind these
are also
the best resolved regions in the map
now we used four different entities for
our structural studies
and these entities are shown here
big tegravir this is the leading
clinically approved drug
this was approved by the fda in 2018
it's one of the best of many drugs that
are used to treat
hiv infected individuals and these three
compounds these are developmental
compounds these are based on a distinct
nafta reading scaffold they've been
developed
by our collaborators at the nih terry
burke
and in collaboration with the virology
lab of steve hughes
so these compounds are based on a
different
scaffold and some of these compounds and
particularly for d
and 4c they are extremely potent and in
fact
more potent than uh big tegravir
when when used
against viral resistant variants now for
those who are interested this is our
table one
just a few things to highlight here we
use the krios with the k2 detector
operating in counting mode we actually
use the range of tilt angles from 20 to
40 degrees
on principle you only need one but we
didn't know which one
would work best so use a small range we
collected with a dose rate that would
minimize coincidence loss
on the k2 while at the same time
maximizing the information content
within each frame so that was about five
electrons per pixel per second
about two thousand micrographs per data
set which after cleaning resulted
in about 150 000 particles within each
of the final maps
and these maps were on average resolved
to 2.6 to 2.7 angstroms within the
active site
which is where insteads bind the one
exception was compound 4c which was
slightly lower resolution so
as with any other sample we used a
fairly comprehensive
strategy for cleaning the data we
used motion core 2 for movie frame
alignment warped ctf
warp for ctf estimation and for particle
picking then we moved directly to 3d
classification and refinement
we actually deliberately skipped the 2d
step we found that 2d classification
tended to weed out good particles that
actually had
a positive contribution to the
resolution of our final map so we
skipped that step
3d classification was performed
iteratively so we
separated the data into two classes we
then discarded the particles from the
bad class
kept the particles in the good class and
then repeated this iteratively until we
found
we saw no more further improvements and
finally we performed beam tilt
refinement
particle polishing and this led to the
reconstructions that were
on average resolved to about 2.8 2.9
angstroms
globally in about 2.6 to 2.7 angstroms
within the catalytic core this is just
showing the resolution
analysis on the left the conserved
intersome core is colored by local
resolution
again the core is resolved to about 2.6
angstrom the peripheral regions are in
the three angstrom range or below
on the right you have the global fsc
showing a global resolution of about 2.8
angstroms
and below that is the euler distribution
plot and a central slice
through the 3dfsc the slice is
shown for the cross section for the most
anisotropic view
which is actually not bad considering
that we that we started with
highly anisotropic reconstructions
now all the analyses that i'll describe
from here on out
were performed with the maps that i just
introduced in the previous slide so
these maps resolved to about 2.6 2.7
angstroms in the active site
but actually in the last several months
we saw this tweet from tom to williger
showing the new density modification
tool
uh implemented in phoenix which
improves the phases of prior vm maps
so he suggests that one could see on
average
0.2 angstrom improvements in density
maps for the cases that
were evaluated and it turned out that
this was also approximately what we saw
when we applied the approach to our
intersome reconstruction so also about
point two angstrom improvements so even
though the analyses that i'll describe
were performed with the low resolution
maps we're now quite
we are now really quite excited that we
have higher resolution data
and uh uh with wish to evaluate
the reconstructions and more generally
about this density modification approach
which seems to really be helpful for
many different data sets
so instead bind to the conserved into
some core
these are uh so there are two active
sites
and accordingly two regions where an
institute would bind this slide
just shows the conserved into some core
for the map
bound to the compound 4d in yellow
that's the density of the 4d compound
and on the right
is the atomic model of the ligand
here we are now looking into the density
of the active site for all the five
reconstructions
that we analyzed in
the course of this project so that's the
april reconstruction and the
reconstructions with
four compounds bacteria for f4d84c
so in all cases the ligand is completely
resolved
another thing that's worth noting is
that we have
many water molecules that are
surrounding the ligand
and and that particular aspect will
become
more obvious in the next slide
so this is a movie of the density in the
atomic model the reconstruction
containing the compound
4d bound to the active site you can
clearly see
you can clearly and completely see the
density of the entire drug
we can refine it into the map without
really
much ambiguity the compound binds two
magnesium ions
so both of these magnesium ions are
resolved in the maps you can see the two
large bumps that are chelated by the
bound ligand magnesium ions are actually
critical to the enzyme they're involved
in the catalytic mechanism of
of integrase for the cleavage reaction
so
what these compounds do what these
insteads do is that they chelate the two
magnesium ions and therefore they block
the enzymatic cleavage reaction
surrounding the ligand you can see there
are lots of water molecules
there's about 10 of them that we that
are
that are evident in this movie and more
that are surrounding the active site so
these water molecules are critical
they're relevant to drug binding they
can be exploited
as i'll show in a later slide for the
purposes of a drug design
and one of the things that we came to
appreciate throughout the course of this
project is that is the relevance of
bound water molecules so you
you really only see them once you start
getting to sub 3 and resolution
but in in this particular instance that
extra
fraction of an angstrom was really
important for improving our
understanding of the
of the active site and the ligand and
ligand binding
here we show more details of the binding
mode this is bigtech revere
bound to the active site you have a
central scaffold containing
electronegative
atoms these electronegative atoms they
chelate
two magnesium ions this is common to all
institutes
on the right you have a halogenated
benzyl ring
this ring forms pi pi stacking
interactions
with a pi pi stacking interaction with
one of the bases of viral dna
now this specific interaction between
the halogenated benzoylmoid and viral
dna nucleotide
this is precisely the reason why instead
is bind into sums
but not free integrase it's the reason
why we need to assemble these complexes
uh these these nuclear protein complexes
in order to understand their binding
modes
here we show how the binding mode of
bictegravir compares
to that of the compound 4d as i
mentioned earlier 4d is a developmental
compound
it's synthesized by our nih
collaborators the group of terry burke
in collaboration with the group of steve
hughes
4d is a leading preclinical candidate
and in fact it has higher potency than
big tegravir against many drug resistant
variants
so with 4d we can see that the core
scaffold is shifted closer to the
magnesium ions
and that's because it's based on
distinct chemistry where
electronegative atoms are actually part
of the central nectarine core
we also see this long extension on the
left side of the molecule
this extension is very important it
contributes
quite significantly to viral potency it
also constitutes the region
that we are actively exploring and
modifying
in order to try and identify compounds
with higher potency
against viral resistant variants
now i already mentioned water molecules
we we see them throughout the active
site
this slide shows the density and the
location
for some of the bound water molecules in
the active site of the april form
uh the april form contains calcium as
well
as well as three of the nc bound forms
these institute form
bound forms contain magnesium in the
active site
medicinal chemists like to look at
figures like this which simplify the
analysis
this is a two dimensional schematic of
how the enzyme binds to the into some
active site
instant interactions and waters
and waters can both be subdivided by
their relative position with respect to
the
plane that is formed by the magnesium
coordinating the
light the ligand scaffold so there's a
core naftaridine scaffold this chelates
the magnesium ions
and also contains the two r groups r2
contains the halogenated benzoylmoidy
stacks against viral dna
the r1 group that's the one that we're
very interested in
and the group that we're actively
modifying
to elicit better binding and better
response
it points toward the bulk solvent
what's important is that the positioning
of its long chain
displaces loosely bound waters now i'm
not showing the data here
but in addition to the structural
interpretations we actually have some md
data that confirms
the water molecules in the bottom left
region of the schematic are loosely
bound
and displacement of these loosely bound
solvent
solvent molecules should be entropically
advantageous
for the compounds
there's a large network of water
molecules above the core scaffold
and also below the core scaffold and we
believe that
both of these networks can potentially
be exploited for the purposes of drug
design
so this is where future computational
chemistry efforts will be important in
order to really understand the
energetics of binding
and the favorability of water
displacement and we're actively
investigating
this area in collaboration with stefano
fourly
at the scripps research institute
so i do want to note that while the hiv
structures have certainly been very
informative
we did know quite a bit about
insta-binding through earlier work
about a decade ago the chiropractor
group solved structures of prototype
foamy virus antisomes
these are endosomes from a simpler
retrovirus
and the complexes were also assembled
and solved with several bound institutes
we learned a lot from that early work a
lot about
instant binding and and also about
mechanisms of viral resistance
the problem is that the active sites of
hiv
and prototype foamy virus synthesis are
not conserved
depending on how you align the
conservation of the catalytic core
domain is around 20 or 30
and there's and there's only about a 40
conservation
in the residues that are mutated by the
virus when
it involves resistance against
dynasty-based therapy
this is really important it's important
because when you overlay the two active
sites they're not identical
this figure shows the rmsd between the
prototype formula virus into some active
site
and the hiv to some active site and it's
mapped onto the structure of the ladder
what one sees is that while much of the
active site is similar
there's a substantial part that is not
there's a substantial deviation
especially in the part in the bottom
uh in the bottom part of the enzyme
the residues that are highlighted in
this figure these are residues that are
frequently mutated by the virus in
patients
these are viral resistant variants many
of them are not conserved between the
two retroviral species
the consequences of this lack of
conservation are profound
if we take one particular compound the
compound 4f
this is a compound that has a sulfhydryl
benzene extension
on the left side of the active site as
its r1 substituent
and we look at how it binds to the hiv
intersome
we see that the chemical group extends
out away from the active site you can
see it on the left
however that exact same compound binds
very differently to the prototype foamy
virus synthesis
so the r1 sulfhydryl benzyl substituent
actually
bends back into a small cleft formed by
the enzyme
and makes intramolecular stacking
interactions with an afternoon core
likewise if we look at the compound 4c
when it's bound to the hiv intercept the
r1
pentanol group extends out toward the
bulk solvent
similar to the compound 4f
however when it's bound to the prototype
fomivirus into some
the group again adapts a configuration
that has shifted closer
to the naftarian core here's a more
direct comparison
on the left is a comparison of the
binding mode of the compound 4f
in the context of the hiv and the
prototype formula viruses
and on the right is a comparison of the
binding mode of the compound 4c
in the context of the hiv and the
prototype formula viruses
now in addition we show that the binding
mode of the more potent compound 4d
it adapts a similar similar
configuration as that of 4c
extending toward the bulk solvent so
what this is telling us is that
if we want to understand how ligands
bind
if we want to utilize the information
for drug design
or for understanding mechanisms of viral
resistance
we have to be working with the correct
construct
this is really critical as i mentioned
before the residues in the active site
are not necessarily conserved
between prototyphomeovirus and hiv
endosomes and this is indicated in the
table
only about 40 of the residues are
identical
those are indicated in green and many of
these residues
are not cons that are not conserved also
happen to be
viral resistant variants and we know
that drug resistance is a major problem
this is a table showing just a small
subset of patient-derived
viral resistant variants from instant
usage in the clinic
there are many emergent drug-resistant
variants
and more that we are likely to see in
the future
here's just a look at some of the
structural differences between the
resistant variants
each one of these panels shows an
overlay of drug resistant variants in
hiv integrase and the corresponding
residues of pfe and grace
you can see that the conformations are
not identical
the differences might be minor if you
think in terms of atomic displacement
however as i showed just a few slides
ago their effects can really be profound
so they can completely alter how the
compound binds in the active site
so if we want to understand the atomic
mechanism
by which resistant variants displace the
compound again we
really need to be working with the real
construct
where are we going with this work many
of you probably know
that we can measure small molecular
efficacy in cells
using ec50 analysis in the last several
slides
i kept emphasizing the point about
resistance
so if we look at how the naftering
compounds perform
to inhibit hiv challenge in cellular
assays
particularly when the virus contains
clinically relevant resistant variants
what one sees is that several of the
naftavidian compounds especially
compound 4d
outperform the clinically used drugs
this is important because all of the
compounds
potently inhibit the wild-type virus
even the poor compounds potentially
inhibit wild type virus
however what we're interested in is not
necessarily inhibiting the wild-type
virus
we've been doing that extremely well for
the last decade
we're interested in how the compounds
inhibit mutant virus that has already
evolved resistance
that's what's going to be relevant for
long-lasting therapy for patients
so we hope that the naftarian compounds
may provide
an avenue towards this goal
in the future what we want to do is we
want to understand how resistant
variants affect
its dividing we want to decipher the
atomic mechanisms that are involved in
this process
we want to use the criaem pipeline for
the purposes of drug design
so we believe that with structural
biology
computational chemistry medicinal
chemistry
we can potentially make a dent in this
area
i just want to finish up with this last
slide
this slide describes the strategy that
we are planning to take to achieve this
goal
it's based on an idea called the
substrate envelope hypothesis
this is an idea that was developed by
celia schiffer's lab
and it was applied to the development of
protease inhibitors
about 15 or 20 years ago the substrate
envelope
is the molecular envelope of an enzyme
that binds
natural substrates so any and all
natural substrates
in the case of protease those substrates
are the amino acids that are
proteolytically cleaved
by the enzyme in the case of integrase
natural substrates are both viral
and target dna and these and these are
displayed in the current figure
so a resistant variant needs to displace
the bond drug
when a resistant mutation arises if it
displaces the drug
while at the same time protruding into
the natural substrate envelope
this can potentially compromise viral
fitness
therefore the resistant variant has less
of a chance to persist in the clonal
viral population
so if you keep the drug constrained to
the substrate envelope
then resistant mutants will compromise
by our fitness and are less likely to be
maintained
in the next generation conversely
if the drug protrudes out of the
substrate envelope
then it's easier for resistant variants
to displace the compound while at the
same time maintaining viral fitness
so therefore as we're optimizing the
compounds
we're now going to be using the hiv set
the hiv into some substrate envelope
to guide us and to make sure that we're
constraining the molecule that we're
uh modifying within its boundaries
to conclude cryovm is experiencing an
exponential growth curve
it's now applicable to drug design
although still relatively low throughput
we've shown that tilting the grid
facilitates high resolution structural
studies
of preferentially oriented samples into
sums are a very nice example of this
we've developed routine workflows for
interstellar inhibition
and structural studies and using these
workflows we can now get
sub three angstrom resolution structures
which provide key insights into
the structural differences the modes of
drug binding
and we're starting to investigate also
the role of solvent and how that
facilitates drunk design we've shown
that
using the correct specimen is absolutely
essential
if you want to modify compounds and
understand vital resistance
you really need to be using the correct
specimen
and finally the substrate envelope
hypothesis
which is not a new idea but is an idea
that is now very
relevant to improving
drugs that are targeting hiv integration
especially
in light of viral resistance
finally these are the people who did the
work dario pasos and ilona joswick in my
group have spearheaded the cryom and the
molecular modeling
respectively this work is part of a
long-standing collaboration with minli
and bob cragy at the nih
we've since developed a strong team of
collaborators
in medicinal chemistry with the group of
terry burke virology with steve hughes
and computational chemistry with
stephanie fourley
we're excited to be continuing all this
work in the future with these folks
i'd like to thank the scripps research
institute with whom we've established
the consortium for utilizing the cryom
infrastructure
computational and crime support both at
salk and tsri
funding sources that have been generous
to us over the last few years
of course thermo fish are scientific in
collaboration with nature publishing
group for giving me the opportunity to
talk about this work
and last but not least all the audience
members who have signed up for this
webinar
thanks and at this point i'd be happy to
take any questions